tras más de un mes de las inundaciones
que devastaron esta región en el sur de
Pakistán zonas enteras siguen
ampliamente damnificadas para llegar
hasta los pueblos a un aislados hay que
alquilar un barco y navegar por este
océano de agua estancada
en el pico de la crisis había entre seis
y nueve metros de agua actualmente
quedan cuatro
trabaja en la oficina forestal conoce
esta región como la palma de su mano y
nos muestra la amplitud de los estragos
esta era una mezquita está bajo el agua
y detrás había una escuela primaria que
también quedó inundada
las Hacienda familias que vivían en este
pueblo tuvieron que abandonarlo todo
ahora está desierto Sólo quedan ruinas
estos hombres dos hermanos Son los
únicos en haber regresado vinimos para
recuperar las estructuras de metal de
nuestra casa vamos a guardarlas para
cuando podamos reconstruir a finales de
agosto estaban en su casa cuando en
medio de la noche empezó a subir el
nivel del agua
el agua llegó del pueblo de al lado
entró muy rápido
por la lluvia ya estaba un poco inundado
Pero eso destruyó todo
tuvimos que llevar a nuestra familias a
un lugar más seguro
desde el comienzo de las inundaciones
más de 33 millones de personas tuvieron
que dejar atrás sus casas lo equivalente
a la mitad de la población francesa
alrededor del lago más grande del país
que todavía se está desbordando
gigantescos campamentos se desplazados
acogen a las familias que esperan el
descenso de las aguas
viven bajo un sol abrasador y en un
hacinamiento extremo
desde hace más de un mes este hombre
comparte una tienda de campaña con su
mujer y sus cinco hijos miren aquí
tenemos nuestra ropa y ahí están las
sábanas
eso fue todo lo que trajimos de nuestro
pueblo perdimos todo por las
inundaciones
entre las miles de familias instaladas
aquí todas o casi todas tienen al menos
un hijo enfermo por las aguas estancadas
proliferan las epidemias net Mohamed
está preocupado por sus hijas
mi hija tiene malaria
me lo dijo el médico
Y mi otra hija también tiene fiebre
nos dieron medicamentos pero no mejoran
hay mucha gente enferma aquí
con la disminución del nivel del agua
algunos de los pueblos más elevados
lentamente han vuelto a emerger varias
familias han regresado a este desde la
semana pasada entre ellos la demir Henry
antes aquí había una casa pero cuando
volvió no encontró más que cúmulos
escombros
miren todos estos ladrillos son los de
las paredes de la habitación que había
antes aquí este pueblo ya había sido
afectado por las terribles inundaciones
de 2010 pero según mirham las de agosto
pasado fueron de una intensidad
incomparable en 2010 no hubo tantas
pérdidas el agua subió bastante pero
esto fue gigantesco nunca había visto
algo parecido
algunos habitantes han podido regresar a
sus casas pero en los alrededores los
campos están totalmente sumergidos este
agricultor está desesperado tras un
episodio de sequía en la primavera
pasada contaba con esta estación para
sembrar trigo
aquí estaban mis tierras
pero con toda esta agua no puedo hacer
nada
según las autoridades pakistaníes será
necesario esperar al menos un mes antes
de que la situación regrese a la
normalidad